foreign
[Music]
the legend Returns the end time Thriller
I Am Legend released back in 2007 and
starring Will Smith is still considered
a big favorite among fans of the genre
and also proved to be a financial
success in 2022 exactly 15 years after
the release of the first movie a sequel
was officially announced it will also
star Will Smith once again as Robert
Neville that should raise some questions
given the ending of part one well in
this new original we'll tell you what
the sequel is all about and give you all
the early details
the plot of I am Legend 2 will probably
lead to a bit of confusion for those who
know the predecessor it was about Robert
Neville who is supposedly the last
living human being in a post-apocalyptic
world and has to fight for his survival
he spent the day hunting antelopes and
sending radio messages to possible
survivors of a global plague at night
however he hides as it is dominated by
the infected who avoid the daylight the
end of the movie was rather sad Robert
catches an infected person and wants to
test a potential cure on them however
this causes other infected individuals
to overrun his lab in the ensuing battle
he dies and his story thus seemed to be
concluded however an alternate ending
was included as part of the film's home
release which explains Robert's return
in the sequel he realizes that the
infected aren't after him at all but
only when a free the woman he captured
he also discovers that the infected are
not soulless Undead at all but
intelligent beings they have created
their own society and simply want to be
left alone after the infected person is
freed Robert is able to join other
survivors on a journey to one of the
last camps where other humans still
exist
I am Legend 2 picks up on the
alternative ending of part one and will
tell a news story based on it in an
interview with deadline screenwriter
Akiva goldsman stated that the sequel
will adhere more closely to the novel
according to him the famous novel by
Richard Matheson was about the fact that
Humanity's time as the dominant species
on the planet had come to an end that he
said was a very interesting point to
explore further the theatrical ending
which was reshot under pressure from the
movie studio totally excluded this
aspect of the novel lead actor Will
Smith also talked about the sequel in an
interview with entertainment tonight at
the beginning of 2022. at first he
didn't believe in a sequel but when he
heard about the idea on which part 2
will now be based he was convinced that
I am Legend 2 could become a good film
he couldn't reveal any more details yet
but Smith believes it's a really really
cool concept
Will Smith won't be the only big name in
I Am Legend 2. at aside we will see
Creed star Michael B Jordan the actor
has already played a number of
impressive roles and recently made his
Dragon debut with Creed 3. first
theories say that he could possibly play
the son of Robert Neville Will Smith
revealed that Jordan also contributed
significantly to the development of part
two Akiva Goldman was already in charge
of Penning the script for part one as
continuing to do so for the follow-up
according to him part 2 is set a few
decades after part 1 and it will be
important to check whether Will Smith
has to be portrayed as older for the
plot than he actually is whether I Am
Legend director Francis Lawrence will
also take over the direction again is
still unclear
Goldman disclosed that the famous video
game The Last of Us will be used as an
inspiration having already been
implemented in a magnificent Series this
year the game impressively shows how
nature reclaimed the Earth after the
outbreak of a pandemic which they also
want to illustrate using New York as an
example on the one hand this statement
is a bit surprising since I Am Legend
already depicted of New York dominated
by Nature many years before The Last of
Us and in turn also served as an
inspiration for The Last of Us on the
other hand the mention of the city
itself attracts attention since Robert
and his companions actually leave the
city at the end of part one at least in
the version they want to refer to
we can look forward to seeing how the
project turns out in the coming months
originally a theatrical release was
planned for 2024 but this seems rather
unrealistic at the moment given the
writers and actor strikes those involved
though leave no doubt that I am Legend 2
will be released sooner or later in any
case there doesn't appear to be any lack
of motivation what about you guys are
you fans of I Am Legend and were you
already acquainted with the alternative
ending which one did you like more and
do you think there's more to the story
let us know your thoughts in the
comments below and be sure to like this
video If you enjoyed it
foreign
[Music]